tu sais que je rêve d'un film d'action
alors pour moi cette comédie romantique
et moi je tranche de coûts pour le film
d'action six semaines en malaisie mec
ce qui veut dire des femmes mal et je
voudrais juste écrire une histoire sur
l'amour tel qu'il est réellement
autrement dit ni drôle ni romantique
mais ça risque d'être un peu déprimant
l'amour c'est déprimant c'est pourquoi
chaque fois qu'une fille m'a dit je
t'aime je t'aime je t'aime je t'aime je
t'aime ma réponse a été hachée du mal à
m'imaginer ressentir la même chose pour
toi un jour je t'avoue et puis j'ai
rencontré cette fille ça vous dit de
faire une expérience sociale jeudi
vous savez de quoi fait mon costume
d'apparat vous fait rêver désolé
allez faites le service est en fait une
tête à toi tu as goûté au kram j'en ai
mangé aussi près seulement être amis non
c'est pas interdire est un homme et une
femme y a pas d'amitié à +41 poisson et
un écureuil tu sais comment je tue les
passions passagère avec une arme à feu
c'est plus facile que tu prends un gars
ont suivi le garçon et la fille qu'on
eût dit marie et ont beaucoup d'enfants
excuse moi est ce que les hommes pensent
le sexe et la réponse à tout ouais bon
jour était en train de tomber amoureux
quand j'ai rencontré ta grand mère elle
était fiancée un italien en revanche toi
t'es pas fichu de battre pour la vie que
tu aimes je veux pas tu pas x 4 et
savoure pas qu'est ce qui te plaît je
t'aime je préfère ceux d'autres et j'ai
cherché une comédie romantique c'est pas
la réalité
on aimerait que ce soit la réalité c'est
tout j'étais des routiers c'est
terrifiant parce que 99 fois sur 100 ça
marche pas mais imaginez une seconde que
cette histoire vous file à peine et
qu'on passe à côté
je sais que je regretterai jusqu'à la
fin mes champs
l'amour n'est pas une pensée rationnelle
c'est un sentiment il moi je me sentais
amoureux